[Music]
and our other big story here at six
o'clock they're known as a symbol of the
west but the majority of wild horses in
this u.s there's a good thing because
they're right here in nevada but the
federal government claims there's not
enough room for them here so they
capture them and the way they capture
them has been controversial for a long
time some of the horses get injured
others die it is an issue the eight news
now i team has been following for
decades and the i-team's vanessa murphy
here with the latest move to address
concerns
denise and brian wild horse advocates
argue the way the bureau of land
management captures wild horses is
inhumane the blm is required by law to
hold hearings about this but this time
there may be even more public outcry
after video we showed right here on
eight news now it also prompted a
federal lawmaker to try to take action
but the roundups with helicopters are
the worst you saw the pictures from the
most recent one at the pancake area near
ely where they chased that little cult
till he just ran down and then they had
to shoot him what purpose does that
serve in a recent interview
congresswoman dina titus first chaired
with the eight news now i-team she wants
to eliminate helicopters during the
capturing of wild horses the i-team
first showed you this video of
contractors hired by the bureau of land
management using a helicopter to chase
this horse with a broken leg the animal
was eventually euthanized but that's
after it had been placed in a truck and
driven on bumpy land this was in january
as the blm captured wild horses at an
area called the pancake complex about a
four hour drive north from las vegas we
need to find another method and the
first thing we can do is get rid of
outlaw ban those helicopters while
congresswoman titus is introducing the
wild horse and borough protection act of
2022 the blm will hold its annual
hearing on the use of the equipment she
wants to ban members of the public can
weigh in virtually on april 26th laura
lee of advocacy group wild horse
education says she's hoping more members
of the public will speak against the
blm's actions and she wants the blm to
take concerns seriously she provided the
i-team with this video and says she'll
continue to expose miss treatment like
this and so that people can see it with
their own eyes and see how urgently
change is needed
according to congresswoman titus those
contractors the blm hires to capture the
horses get about five to eight hundred
dollars per horse she says fertility
control is more cost effective and it
would save taxpayers money denise we've
previously reported on a program where
they use darts and we've learned that
the biden administration set aside more
money recently for fertility control
right um so i know that some people
there's so many different opinions on
this topic but some people say you know
what just leave them alone let them just
do their own thing some people believe
the blm puts other interests ahead of
the wild horses uh like ranching they
also think the blm just needs a better
plan overall more stories at
eightnewsnow.com on that for our viewers
also information about that upcoming
hearing